Civil liberties are inherent human
rights.
Some people use the terminology,
terminology,
natural rights.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
a resonant passage that many people can
relate to is the declaration of
independence with one amendment.
You can guess a,
when it says all men are created equal
and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life,
liberty,
uh,
so forth and that too.
And that the purpose of government is to
secure these rights.
And that concept is repeated in the
preamble to the constitution,
which sets forth the purposes of the new
government.
And one of them is to secure the
blessings of liberty to ourselves and
our posterity.
And again,
it doesn't say to provide liberty,
uh,
to grant liberty to bestow it.
No,
we already are entitled to that by
virtue of being born human rather than
giving us liberty government's purpose
is to protect the liberty that we
already have.
Now it's one thing to say that on paper,
and I really,
you know,
for all the shortcomings,
I do think it really was an,
obviously we were nowhere close to those
ideals when the declaration was panned.
And yet it's so significant that those
were the aspirations of this new
government.
It was the first time in history that a
government was dedicated to those
libertarian and egalitarian ideals and
the Hclu,
um,
uh,
founders recognize that,
these rights,
we're not going to be self executing,
that government officials were not
necessarily spontaneously going to
fulfill that responsibility to protect
people's rights rather than suppressing
their rights and,
and had this radical idea that they
would actually do what's necessary,
uh,
to help people who first of all be aware
of what their rights are.
And secondly,
to do what's necessary to protect them
through every possible means.
I think we're best known for litigation,
but from the beginning we have been
extremely active in legislative arenas
as well.
And in a public forum
to define
what is a civil liberty is quite similar
to what the United States Supreme Court
does when it tries to interpret the word
liberty,
which appears in a couple of crucial
passages in the constitution,
including in the bill of rights.
And,
uh,
but I do have to stress one difference,
which is the ACLU is not the American
Constitutional Law Union.
People will often ask me,
you know,
why aren't you doing more to enforce the
second amendment or how we interpret the
Second Amendment,
the right to bear arms.
And,
uh,
you know,
for us the question is,
should something be a fundamental human
right?
And if the constitution is a tool that
we can use to enforce it,
fine.
But if the constitution does not avail
to those purposes,
then we will look for another tool.
And let me give you one concrete example
and then I'll come back to the more
abstract question.
Uh,
so for example,
and this surprises many people,
there is no constitutional right to be
free from racial discrimination by any
entity or individual aside from the
government.
The constitution only applies to
governmental actions.
And so therefore,
until we had the 1964 civil rights act,
private employers,
private restaurants,
private corporations,
landlords,
you name it,
we're completely free to discriminate in
the most blatant ways on any basis they
chose including race.
The constitution simply did not apply.
The Aclu therefore lobbied very hard for
the civil rights law,
uh,
because we believe that there is a
fundamental civil liberty to be free
from racial and other forms of
demographic discrimination when you're
dealing with major aggregations of
private power,
uh,
in the employment,
in the workplace,
in housing and so forth.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you know,
civil libertarians will debate and
disagree among ourselves over particular
issues.
And it's certainly true that,
uh,
abortion,
to the best of my knowledge,
was not expressly on the ACL Ooh,
radar screen until sometime in the,
uh,
I believe 1960s.
And,
uh,
I do know this,
that the acl Ou was the first national
organization to call for a woman's right
to choose an abortion to be protected
under the constitution.
I think it's an organic outgrowth of
work that we had from the beginning.
One of our earliest clients back in the
1920s,
our first decade of existence was
Margaret Sanger.
We also represented Emma Goldman,
and these were two women who were
advocating what I think of is exactly
the same,
right?
Which is a woman's right to information
and decisional autonomy,
uh,
about her reproductive options and,
medical information and assistance to
carry out an informed choice in those
areas.